what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich russell
just trying to get our lunch
money right i'm here with beautiful
intelligent evil marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p she's got her sailor outfit on
and we are ready to go
hold on block five is now the sponsor of
lunch money go get a block by account
go to lunch go to blockfi.com not lunch
money go to blockbuy.com
you can earn up to 8.6 apy in an
interest bearing account
go to blockfy.com pop
what's up did you see that i texted you
like a few minutes ago you didn't
respond to me
uh i texted him when i was in the other
room and i said oh my god did you see
that bitcoin's almost at 42
000 and i didn't get a response back
guys
i did not get a reply i did not get an
acknowledgement
of my excitement for bitcoin imagine if
i texted you from the other room
you do that's true
so bitcoin is gonna keep going oops 41
000 which means climbing 40 percent so
far this year
this year has gone up more so far in
2021
than double what the s p did last year
damn
yeah but it could also fall so it's very
volatile pay attention
volatile it's kind of like me i think
bitcoin is like me
i'm volatile sometimes sometimes i'm
very calm and then sometimes i'm
volatile then
okay um enough about me because
bitcoin's been worth a million dollars
by the
end of 2020s i believe i explained it
yesterday and i wrote about this morning
go ahead
next anthony don't be putting price
predictions out there because then i'm
going to have the people
tweeting at me being like oh did you
know though
just saying all right economy sees
job loss in december for the first time
in eight months as
surging virus takes toll um
basically the labor department reported
friday that non-farm payrolls fell
by a hundred and forty thousand dollar
dollars 140
000 that was below expectations for 50
000 from economists
it was the first monthly drop since
april
wow april was bad well april's bad and i
mean recovery
recovery was because literally you just
had people getting hired back after
they all lost their jobs in march and
april but uh this is not good
this is not good at all because it means
that we may have peaked
and if we peaked that's not good
but we will see i think that there will
be plenty of job creation coming from
here i expect a small
business renaissance renaissance
new business applications are way up
like i think it's like 30 or 40 percent
up year over year of course everyone's
gotta start businesses i wonder
yeah i mean the pandemic obviously was
terrible for people who
well got sick and lost their jobs but in
terms of like the economic impact
i wonder if actually it was a little
freeing for some people to be like you
know what you fired me from this journal
but i'm gonna start my business that
i've always wanted to start
hey if you think about it okay
and people lose their jobs and they have
a dream they're gonna go after it
good for those people i hope that
everyone starts their own business i do
too honestly
financial freedom let's go i love not
working for anybody else
you work for me don't even that's why i
didn't say anything go ahead
okay online finance startup sofi is set
to go public by merging with a blank
check
company spec attack uh run by venture
capital investor chamath palapatiya
the merger with liberty spec social
capital heat of sofia corp5
will value sofa at 8.65 billion
dollars wow hey so five multi-billion
dollar company bang bang let's
roll i kind of forgot about sofi to be
honest right sorry i mean you have to
remember like
the the company is uh still growing it's
got a great product they've really
expanded the product suite
and uh at some point they're gonna have
to go public and so to go public via
spec makes a lot of sense jamaat is like
taking all these
companies public yeah he figured out
that the pr that the technology
companies want to get into the public
markets he figured out a better way to
do it
they trust him because him and anthony
noto or
anthony noto probably trusts him because
he really understands anthony noodle's
the ceo
yeah he understands technology companies
um and so it's a great kind of win-win
tesla surpassed facebook by market cap
tesla's stock jumped about 5.5 percent
at 903 am to give it a market cap of
802.6
billion while facebook stock dipped
facebook now has a
market cap of about 755.8 million
billion do you like my dramatic reading
of the market caps
i'm gonna i'm gonna start a podcast
called dramatic market cap readings with
paulina
uh of course tesla's gonna be one of the
most valuable companies well they
are one of the most valuable companies
in the world but like i think that it
has the potential to be the most
valuable company in the world
it tesla is going to bring the world off
of
uh fossil fuels and it's going to bring
them into the
clean energy era is it going to take us
to mars
uh tesla won't but spacex will i
actually i actually think that there's a
chance that
elon musk uh creates a legal entity and
he puts spacex
tesla what he was talking about and
other things inside of it yeah
i think it's possible why would that be
beneficial for him
or well just because actually if you
think about tesla
and spacex they're much more related
than people
thought or that they appear on the
surface
i'm gonna take a picture of all the
empty things you have on this table that
belong in the trash
okay um roku announced
friday that it has acquired quibby's
library of content it's no longer just a
rumor stop
moving oh my god you're going to pick
that up
anthony i just threw him
and they on the couch oh and he go pick
them up oh
no they're all on the floor because you
missed the couch okay
they hit the couch then they filmed so
quivi
is its library of content is being
bought by
roku this was just the rumor but now it
is reality
and it is a happy somewhat happy ending
for the sad tragedy of a startup sorry
they didn't get enough money to recover
to return investors capital though
but they got they raised like one no 1.7
billion is how much they raise
something like that absurd and so what's
gonna happen to the investors who put
the money in
they lost their money that's the risk
you take eek
that's what happens next it's ask lunch
money time please
ask your questions politely in the
comment section below with hashtag
ask lm it can be about anything it
doesn't just have to be
at him or about him it could be about it
it could be about me
huh go ahead in my dramatic readings of
market caps okay
so daniel bella fonte
i think it's bellafonte it could be
belafont but i like this name
asks pimp and pump it's not bellafonte
there's a r
bella front oh sorry oh my god
bella front at least one of us can see
and read around here
stop you're messing up the table so
pimping pomp
thank you daniel i almost i am sorry you
should come on i mean i get my name
butchered all the time so i don't feel
good about doing it to other people
pimp and pump political opinions
political opinions
aside as a former facebook employee
anthony what are your thoughts on the
platform
banning trump at least until his term is
over
i don't want to live in a world where
social media
platforms are the arbitrator of truth
i don't want to live in a world where
social media companies are able to
censor people based on
comments i don't think that
it is a good precedent to set where a
platform a technology
executive can make a decision to
de-platform the president of the united
states
what would happen if right now there's a
terrorist attack
what would happen right now if there was
some need for the president to
communicate
with people it's not a good precedent
with that said
i think this is fully within facebook's
right to do it if they want to do it
yeah in the sense of they're a private
company so
okay good they're they're publicly
traded company but but they're in the
private market they
it's a for-profit business they can do
whatever they want to do they have their
terms of service they can choose to deny
service to anyone
they want so it's not that i think that
they're breaking the law
or doing something they're not allowed
to do i just think that
they are making a mistake in
choosing to remove the president which
by the way
oh go ahead no go ahead i was gonna say
by the way
of all the things that the president has
said and done
that's what you removed him for for a
video where he literally told people wow
don't create violence
hold on good so hi i'm paulina i'm here
for nuance
so again let me reiterate inciting a
riot
is not covered by freedom of speech
that is not covered i find it bizarre
that they removed
the or they yeah they removed the video
but not his
call to that right is that correct
they removed the the second video not
like
okay whatever it doesn't matter but i
think people
might think oh this is good because
they're removing something that is
inciting a riot which is not covered by
freedom of speech that is good in the
short term but it's dangerous it says a
dangerous precedent
in the long term where we are now saying
it's okay for mark zuckerberg and jack
dorsey to decide
what's okay to say and what's not
the fact that it wasn't just that one
instance the fact that they're
completely de-platforming him
i think is a little dangerous for
the future because suddenly like yes
it's trump he has a lot
of power and people follow him etc some
people are able to look at his
uh message and ideas and think for
themselves and say okay like rationally
like maybe this
is not a good thing to do but there are
other people who read it and they're
like we should go to the capitol in our
bare hats
like that is you know it's just it's so
interesting but
it it's um there's a lot of ethical
implications for the future of freedom
of speech now that we're letting these
technology companies
decide who's gonna be part of them and
not
yeah and i think that it's just again um
there's no right decision like that's
the scary part here is no matter what
decision you make people are going to be
upset
some portion of the population but it is
just uh
i think a really slippery slope um again
it's within their right they can do it
that's fine um so i like the fact that
they're able to do it
in this you know like they have the
right to do it if they want i just don't
think that it's necessarily the right uh
the right step and by the way once he's
not president
it would not surprise me if we see all
the platforms trying to take them off
which is even crazier because then he's
not even the president anymore
so uh yeah we'll see but um
it will be very interesting to watch
what happens over the next six months or
so
yeah all right cool well thank you guys
everyone have a great weekend see you on
monday oh it's friday
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest
on a deposit in an interest-bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but eight point six
percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends